and over those years i've gone back to
beautiful sites
and been confronted with this and it
made me wonder
what i was doing to help save the forest
and i began to wonder if in 50 years are
we going to have
any force left in madagascar and without
forest
what does that mean for all the people
i've worked with all the people i've
gotten to know and care about
population has doubled since the time i
started working in madagascar
what does that mean for the future now
that's a problem that the world has to
come to terms with it's not just
from madagascar but we have extended
ourselves well
beyond our normal means for using
landscapes
so i began to think i need to change as
an entomologist there's a role i can
play and it
has to happen quick and i began to think
about the people and the landscapes i
realized i have to stop
working just in those pristine little
dots
and begin to work with the people that
live around those forests
and it comes down to how are they going
to feed their kids
if they can't access the forest if they
can't cut down
the trees to grow new crops if they
can't hunt for bush meat
and kill the lemurs how are they going
to feed their kids they're running
out of options there's already migration
where people are moving and looking for
new possibilities and there are none
that meant coming up with a new solution
and i call that the
breakfast before conservation now as
entomologist
at first i thought i had no role to play
in this
but then i just started looking around i
was kind of blind to this but do you see
it
those are insects there in madagascar
they eat
edible insects now insects you may have
heard about this now that more and more
people are turning to insects
for lots of reasons in fact it just
makes sense
insects unlike warm-blooded animals like
a cow or a pig
you don't have to waste energy on
heating the body you don't have to give
it extra water so it can sweat
looking at it in terms of gains for
insects and compared to cattle
where it takes like 2 000 gallons of
water to get a pound of
protein compared to only like 50 gallons
for a cricket
protein also in terms of space and
impact on co2 it takes six times the
feed
to get a pound from a cow compared to a
cricket for example
so that simple conversion rate even if
you're feeding at the same thing
you'll get six times the protein if
you're feeding it to an insect
compared to a cattle in fact studies
have shown that you can absorb
more micronutrients from eating insects
than a slab of steak so you have
efficient conversion rates you have
more micronutrients and more studies are
now showing that it improves our
microbiome
if you eat insects so it just makes
sense
so i wanted to see if there was
potential of building on that tradition
in madagascar
and finding maybe potential native
species in which we could actually farm
so to begin that going through the
history of the last 400
years and reading about what people ate
before
and digging up recipes and documenting
it
and there's some really interesting
discoveries there in fact the first
insect mentioned in 1658 was
this cicada called a flathead in fact
they didn't even know it wasn't cicada
like they called it a butterfly then
they called it an ant but actually
this insect the red ones there that look
like flowers they
tap into phloem and actually exude a
bunch of
sugar because they have to look for
micronutrients in the phloem
inside the plant so they create these
fist-sized piles of sugar
that the locals would gather up and eat
so with the
lemurs too but this was highly sought
after in fact
during the colonial period a french
botanist actually
tried to farm these and create this mana
he called
in madagascar using this incredible
flathead
but the real star of this group of
insects is what's called the sacundry
the one with the strange
kind of harness on his head there now
these are amazing and this was the other
most talked about insect in this group
in the literature because
everybody loved to eat it it tastes like
bacon
the locals call it sacundry but in
english you can call it the bacon bug
like bacon you can just put it in a pot
and fry it up in its own grease
and it's delicious going back and
reading through the history
we also discovered that one group of
insects
was the most easily absorbed in other
types of cuisines
and that was the pupa from silk moth
french chefs in madagascar would
actually serve it in the
french residence in 1884 and they would
describe it as some
butterfly brains because it tasted like
veal brains
and even the last queen of madagascar
used to have special
helpers that would scour the countryside
for these types of edible insects
including the silk moth pupa and also
locust and to my surprise i didn't even
see this before
just next to our center in the capital
of madagascar
they sell pupa of soup moths
and do note that they're selling it next
to shrimp
which is actually also a crustacean so
it's actually phylogenetically the
correct place to sell it in the
market and it's actually sold at the
same price as shrimp
in other words historically they valued
edible insects
they're that sold at a very high price
and there's a long tradition of it